episcopal high school in alexandria
virginia has a long more than 150-year
long history it's an impressive school
one of the best in the country a lot of
impressive people have gone there but
like so many schools
it's becoming a woke factory thanks to
its leadership bad leadership
now a 17 year old student at that school
is facing harassment
from the school from her teachers for
posting positive
conservative content on social media
pretty moderate stuff
to give just one example in a direct
message on instagram a teacher
dismissed this student will call her by
her first name mackenzie
with a slur a nasty slur too a little
blank
according to mckenzie's attorney jesse
bennell the school is planning on
hauling the girl before a disciplinary
committee for the crime
of having divergent views jesse middle
joins us tonight
jesse thanks so much for coming on so if
this is an outrage on its face but it's
also representative of so much that's
going
on in the country right now but i'd love
to get granular quickly on
what she did wrong thanks tucker
and it really is outrageous because what
she did wrong
the only thing that they can really
point to that she did wrong
is point uh is uh uh have mainstream
conservative uh content on her instagram
account
something that she shared from
mainstream sources like turning point
usa
in prager university stuff that we see
every day that's
very uh normal for for someone who
believes in conservative principles to
have
and the school went crazy in fact
what's really incredible is what started
all this
was that she decided to post
sympathies for the family of david dorn
a retired police officer who was killed
by rioters
and her classmates went crazy and
started attacking her
body shaming her they uh
attacked her for a prior interracial
relationship that she was in
they absolutely were just vile and it
wasn't
even as you pointed out it wasn't even
just students it was an alum
of the uh of the school and it was a
teacher at the school and now we're in
this spot where they've decided to
to to use awoke phrase they're going to
victim shame
and and the uh they've decided instead
of holding her attackers to account
they're going to hail mackenzie right
before
a disciplinary committee where they're
not going to tell her exactly when it's
going to be it's really incredible
it's unbelievable these schools are
extremely expensive and if they
keep this up they will go out of
business this cannot continue people
will not send their kids to places like
this
unfortunately it was a great school
jesse i'm glad that her family's hired
you in godspeed
thank you so much tucker